salut chirac à la france vous vivez avec
votre temps et ça c'est bien oui quand
même
le san francisco lycée jean bart il
connaissait julie ferrier il a mal à sa
france apparemment alors on va prendre
des nouvelles de dupes a fait également
de détecter certains acteurs comme
lorànt deutsch
salut tout le monde a alors moi c'est
pas compliqué j'adore julie et j'en
arrive parce que leur spectacle ils
comique de la joie et la gaieté gaîté
montparnasse une pièce satirique
d'alluré en 1937 et s'élance au monde
magazine
le truc que j'adore encore plus que vos
invités
c'est le métro mais vraiment je trouve
super julie et jean-marie parce que
c'est des gens qui l'ouvrent louve
rivoli la tasse tiers seulement des
malades dont l'entrée se faisait
initialement par la conel mance a alors
annoncé michel cymes qui venu nous voir
bonjour cyril bonjour à toute l'équipe
alors jean marie bigard et moi on a un
point commun c'est qu'on n'hésite pas à
appeler une chatte une chatte par
exemple dans le magazine de la santé si
on parle d' infections urinaires
je demande la marina la co-présentatrice
si elle connaît la différence entre une
cystite et des bonbons acidulés n'y
aurait pas dans les deux cas ça pis que
les lèvres et sinon est ce que vous
connaissez la différence
qu'est-ce qui vous connaissez la
différence entre elodie gossuin et une
gastro tiens une des deux qu'on a
beaucoup plus envie d'attraper que
l'autre cyril
sur l'échangé mots si vous avez changé
pas compris par les comptes annuels de
carglass pourquoi carla 100 places mon
client
j'avais plusieurs impacts 60 ha breizh
faut dire que c'est complètement con
d'aller faire du camping en syrie son
pare brise était complètement mort 1
mon client aussi d'ailleurs mais bon on
a quand même envoyé olivier de carglass
pour remplacer le pare brise
résultat on a changé le pare brise par
contre pour olivier on n'a rien pu faire
et oui ils avaient un impact d'une
taille supérieure à une pièce de deux
euros
bon je vous laisse il faut que j'aille
donner des cours de comédie à jo
wilfried tsonga pour la pub kinder bueno
atteint avant qu'ils partent au brésil
ce qui va bientôt partir au brésil c'est
franck ribéry un bonjour monsieur
hamouma c'est moi que c'est frau kribi
bon c'est pour dire que j'aime bien de
regarder votre émission
ben celle que je préfère mieux c'est
isabelle morini bosc
ouais parce que comme qu'est ce qu'elle
dit ça dure longtemps on a bien le temps
de comprendre ce qu'elle dit
place mon client et henri l avait
plusieurs impacts de pare brise sur son
visage
non non
il était complètement fêlé oh non non
non j'ai tant de la résine
on n'a rien pu faire pour lui au nom
résultat mon client il ressemblait le
xsara picasso beaucoup à demain je crois
que jean marie bigard baveux veut réagir
pape avoue jean marié ce jean marie
bigard la hâte en syrie mais puisqu'on
parlait de ribéry y en a une qui m'a
choqué c'est la petite zahia attend on a
l'impression qu'elle est tout un
plastique ou en cuir normal que plein de
footballeurs envie de taper dedans tu as
vu comment les gaules à la petite zahia
geoffrey bien moins quatre heures tu
sais qu'elle est tellement cambrai que
sa tête est en décalage horaire avec son
fion
de même que des fois larry avec cinq
minutes d'avancé sur son cul de coprim
amis